[Music]
oh Brendan no
no I wasn't oh no not I know that's not
you
it wasn't on the screen yet that's why I
was like hilarious okay so Brendan
uh something another Brendan thing that
I thought was really fun to watch is
that Brendan's going to talk about the
Rock and the UFC deal that he said ready
it's so good the rock shoes uh Terence
McKinney is calling out the rock about
it
I love doing this mechanic too he's a
great fellow sliders asked where the
rock shoot so Tennessee can he put come
on man with a Emoji of you know covering
the face is he okay
no bro can you the answer is no by the
way I found out Mark Carly's the one
running all his socials it's like come
on dude it says uh bloody elbow shout
out to bloody elbow at bloody hell we'll
put Fighters the Shob show is also a
show how many shows
um he has the shop show he has the
fighter and the kid it's too many shows
he has uh the food truck show he has the
king and the sting in the wing and the
Bing and the wing and the ding here's
what I don't understand about these
[ __ ] guys right
it to me would be more work to do six
different shows than one show yeah so
it's like I get like some of these guys
are doing as many shows as we and Royce
do but at least me and Royce are like
all right we got two I do two shows and
Royce does two shows okay I try to keep
it [ __ ] simple could you imagine
trying to sell people on five different
things go over check me out and me and
Royce could be doing the wrestling
Roundup on Thursday at 7 30 and then but
then we get back to Revenge of the
soonest on Friday would just be all over
the place
he's got one show for every working
brain cell in his [ __ ] Acorn break
okay five I choose but won't get paid
for the new UFC sponsorship uh-uh and
then this is what uh Karen says Chad
says Hey brother if you're a fan of what
we do the deal uh if you're a fan of
what we do Brendan reading
if you're but no no no but if you both
are dude fan bruh fam and I know that I
can I I [ __ ] up with reading quite a bit
but I I want you to look at him struggle
like a kid that doesn't know how to read
look at his face while he reads it says
Hey brother if you're a fan of what we
do the deal uh if you're a fan of what
we do make the deal favorable for the
ones modeling your shoe I think it's not
your fault or your business doing it to
us but show us the love you think uh you
think you are get in our corn and
support us
Iraq if you just hey Rock because you
know the rock tunes into shop show of
course hey Rock if you just took a
fraction of what you made on Jumanji 19
or the [ __ ] you're shooting next Jumanji
19.
mush-mouth idiot and sent it to the
fighters they'd be stoked dude The
Rock's job is not to pay the fighters
you [ __ ] nincompoop and also
communist gobbledygook and also it would
send a terrible message considering Dana
White just hired the rock right to have
a deal with the UFC so now you're gonna
the rock is going the first thing he's
gonna do is undermine them and it's
shaking down and confirm no not even
worse and confirm that Dana White's
Gonna Let The Rock give them money out
of his own pocket to confirm that Dana
White doesn't pay them enough do you
know how bad for business that is you're
a [ __ ] legitimate
hard
yes
agreed yeah can you can you just imagine
like if I'm a rock
you know what bro
could you imagine him being like that
Austin Shaw WrestleMania X7 he'd be the
rock but with greasies
that's what he should do start calling
himself The Rock [ __ ]
let's say there was a thick boy shoe
right and there will be a thick boy shoe
very soon they have thick boy shoes
they're called Crocs that's what all the
retards wear
I'm sure Rock's way business I am but
even at the level hold on guys pretty
sure guys he
I'm gonna believe it is here maybe I
don't know man he does have five shows
so you know
good
it's hard
that I'm at I don't know a lot of things
going on with my business or your brain
until it becomes an issue he doesn't
know a lot of things going on with his
business bro you run a YouTube channel
it's not a hard to download YouTube
Studio on your phone and keep up with it
right
and also it just pisses me off right
because uh these guys always [ __ ] about
like oh man I'm running this business
I'm so busy and it's like yeah it's kind
of not super easy to run a show
especially every day and if it's big and
[ __ ] right but like you also have like a
team of people that work for you
full-time
I we don't have that I would kill to
have like two people that just did our
bidding like all day a lot where when
somebody goes hey I didn't get a t-shirt
from this you just text like the same
guy go like get fix this right if the
sound quality you know you'll fix that
next time I want to re-upload it or like
it's still it's like they act like oh
man I got so much stuff to do it's like
all right try doing [ __ ] 20 shows a
week like both of us do and then also
try to get all your [ __ ] in so it's not
easy when you don't have [ __ ] a bunch
of you know a bunch of hopeful probably
up and coming shitty comedians like Mark
Harley that want to be like maybe get on
Rogan one day so he can talk about
[ __ ] Deca and like they'll do your
bidding
about Deca good good call
um so I'm sure Rock didn't know
someone's like yeah you know they
probably came hey you know UFC fights
you can wear your shoes and Rock's like
oh sick man
but they don't they don't know the game
the rock is not your union
representative The Rock's not your agent
they don't they don't know the game no
let me tell you something I promise you
this about The Rock The Rock understands
does he think that the The Rock's on
Twitter bro he understands all the
[ __ ] stuff you don't think that the
rock saw Dana White talking [ __ ] on you
of course he did here's the problem it's
more said do you think Elden ring Elden
ring was was a sponsor for for the UFC
why didn't Elden ring did why did an
elder ring give half of their profits to
the fighters rain energy drink why
didn't they give a [ __ ] Aviation gin why
didn't gay right these these companies
and The Rock they're doing this to
benefit their product that's speaking
speaking of rain energy look what's up
right next to his [ __ ] right shoulder
right there I just noticed I just
noticed
Buck Reebok to go winner sponsor UFC me
sick man all the guys gonna be stoked
about gear we're not stoked
we're not still you're not a UFC fighter
anymore we there's no we there's no we
see me sick man all because being a UFC
fighter is like being in the Marine
Corps man you never get you never shut
the [ __ ] up about it yeah
we're not stoked it ruined your brand
you think that The Rock
having issues with UFC
it ruined his brand
are you completely stupid
oh no The Rock's finished
top comment watching Brennan compare
himself to the rock is the best stand-up
he's ever done
he didn't compare himself he said that
you know the Rock's probably bigger than
him
you're [ __ ] have you heard of Reebok
since the worst business Choice they've
ever made in their lives Nate name the
last time you saw somebody wearing
Reeboks name the last time you saw
somebody win a Reebok fight kit it
literally ruined the reputation no it
didn't Reebok was DOA before that
nobody was wearing Reeboks for a while
this guy thinks that these companies are
losing money because do you think that
the average UFC person that pays for a
pay-per-view is not going to buy a
pay-per-view because they don't think
Fighters are getting paid enough they
don't care
you you know why Dana White doesn't want
to pay Fighters more because he doesn't
have to because they want to fight there
and people are still buying the
pay-per-views it may be people stop
buying the pay-per-views and said we
want fighters to get paid more and fight
there was another alternative that
didn't fall apart like every single
other one then maybe you'd have
something but here's the problem thick
boy I don't see you giving a percentage
of your money that you make from your
stand up from your soul time special
from your five shows even I know you
can't pay all the fighters but why
haven't you started a fund to pay the
fighters and donate a 50 you got money
you don't need all of it right that's
what you're saying to the Rock right why
don't you do it and by the way thick boy
let's not talk about ruining Brands okay
you almost you almost had [ __ ] Brian
Callan kill Bobby Lee over some internet
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're suing a drunk
YouTuber and and on top of that you're
having bent pixels take everybody's
video down to talk [ __ ] about you and
even your [ __ ] daddy Rogan who says
he's ride or die with you is criticizing
you on the biggest podcast in the world
you are a ruined brand you [ __ ] [ __ ]
the only thing worse than Gringo poppy
was the fact that I've had to see it
more than once for this show
sorry I hate him he the The Audacity Of
Brendan sharp giving advice to one of
the most successful businessmen and
actors and [ __ ] [ __ ] marketer in
the world is hilarious to me hey hey you
know he might have a point uh Show links
uh race I put an article about you know
the Rock's dying brand
uh yeah okay now hold on you're a good
cause Reggie let's read an article
[Laughter]
let me see the article about The Rock's
brand that he just ruined okay guys it's
gonna be good
um
where is it show link oh there it is got
it uh let's see here the Rock movie
movies a list of upcoming Rock films
starring between The Rock Johnson oh my
God he's going to be in DC League of
Super Pets he's going to be in Black
Adam he's going to be in red one he's
going to be in San Andreas too he's
going to be in Doc Savage he's going to
be in a remake of Big Trouble in Little
China he's going to be in a movie called
The King he this this yeah his brand is
ruined
because you know what's now watch is
going to start all these movies are
going to start pulling the rock out now
I would say that Brandon shop thinks
he's the king maker but he can't even
keep the sting to stay so yeah not their
fault steam keeper yeah seriously for
real too much that's a king maker and
he's only the wing keeper because that
guy was almost [ __ ] canceled yeah he
still is kind of he's happy yeah he's
still half canceled he's canceled-ish
yeah there's nothing to do with him they
just don't know the game so with the
rock dude you got your tequila that's
popping but again I'm the alley cat
version of The Rock what what he did not
he didn't
he didn't
he didn't
that may be
the dumbest thing he's ever said
it's up there
right I'm the poor man's the only thing
you have in common with the rock is that
you probably have had both of you have a
gyno surgery but that's about it bro and
both of you have probably had gay
experiences
and both of you have probably [ __ ] in
a an overpriced pickup truck
virtual Rock I got my whiskey I got my
merch I got you know I'm touring he's
doing all his [ __ ] they're the same guy
you know what you know what here you
know what this is like Marsh you don't
remember when we were kids The shab Rock
thing is like when we were kids and it
was like the Stallone Schwarzenegger
thing you know where like they're both
two stars they're both huge Stars yeah
it's hard to even tell them apart really
are they ever gonna do a movie together
so for the rock dude everything's going
well I'm going good I'm telling you dude
you force and again it's not your fault
you know what the [ __ ] how the business
Works The Rock's gonna do a movie in an
alternate universe like Last Action Hero
and there's gonna be a poster for the
for the mummy King The Scorpion King and
it's gonna be [ __ ] Brendan Schaub on
the cover
they have the Terminator poster with
Sylvester Stallone on it by the way I
still want one of those by the way I
want the [ __ ] Terminator 2 poster
that has Sylvester Stallone on it that
they made for Last Action Hero
by the way wait we were talking about
the soft air but wait till our thick boy
with four C's and a z after the Y comes
out we're gonna do thick boys sure sue
us come on sue us
sorry but I know the league I know the
legal definition of parody buddy you
force in this again it's not your fault
you know what the [ __ ] how the business
works but you force these fighters to
wear those
can we bring him up I'm a singer you
force
he's a sneaker head
a men that are sneakerheads you're women
okay you know who likes shoes that much
women
fighters to wear your [ __ ] shoes and
you're not gonna pay them
I would love they do pay you I would
love they pay them and part of their
deal that they signed the contract is
they pay them to well the merchandise
they tell them to wear love to hear the
explanation where you think that's okay
oh I'll tell you I'll I'll tell you why
I think it's okay because the rock
literally worked in WWE which was even
worse than the UFC you think
UFC as a [ __ ] slave trade you should
see WWE WWE wrestlers would [ __ ] kill
people to have the power that UFC
fighters have
you know this is hilarious
they you know what the difference is UFC
fighters are still allowed to have
twitch channels
yeah they're allowed to pretty much do
whatever they want outside of it they
could do it they can even talk [ __ ]
about the business when they leave it as
long as they're good Fighters and you
only have to really fight it once every
two to three months yeah so honestly
Brendan shut the [ __ ] up
I think these yeah this one
this one what's wrong with those shoes
I'm sorry I'm not I'm not I'm not crazy
or anything but like
those just look like sneakers that I'd
wear to the gym Am I Wrong is there is
there something I'm seeing about these
shoes that are different than the shoes
that he has behind him what's wrong with
these shoes
he's saying they're horrendous they just
look like [ __ ] gym shoes
I'm not mad at them but usually every
Under Armor shoe I saw was just like I
could never I never never no you look
like a [ __ ] tool they might as well
be Sketchers
Brendan Schwab is worried about dressing
like a [ __ ] tool hold on a second can
I ask a question here this this shows
you his his mental age and he still
thinks he's 19 wearing tight jeans
do any guys
care like I'd I'll be honest with you
right now I don't really care that much
about shoes like you know I have some
nice shoes but like I don't care about
them enough to go like I would wear that
shoe to the gym and wouldn't think twice
about it would you care
like that looks like a regular Under
Armor Shoe Right cheers yeah I'd go if
they're comfortable by the way it's what
he just said this is just shob's way of
trying to stir the pot and he's bad at
it yeah yeah watch watch under Armor's
shoe I saw was just like I could never I
never never yeah man you look like a
[ __ ] tool they might as well be
Sketchers I'm sorry but as it is a 40
year old man I don't understand the
insult of saying they might as well be
Skechers if I find a pair of Skechers
that are comfortable and look okay I'll
buy them like right
who cares simple enough what I don't buy
shoes based on the brand I buy shoes
based on like oh those will be good for
the gym oh those would be good for
walking oh those would look nice if I go
out I don't go like oh my God Under
Armor
who the hell cares your child brain this
is the problem with these La comics and
it's not just Brendan because they're
all like this because Brendan's not
smart enough to develop his own thoughts
Brennan just copies his environment
around him okay because if Brennan if if
this same Brendan
Brennan was in the was in the New York
comedy scene he'd be saying things like
dead ass and stuff like that because
that is because he would be mimicking
them because he doesn't have anything
you're a joke Brendan you're a [ __ ]
joke and the fact that you think if you
were Under Armor shoes that's what makes
you look like a tool and not the fact
that you were that even you made you
were the tightest jeans on the planet
Brendan stop it
but those they're those are kind of
Letty especially the the red ones with
the cement bottoms okay not too bad and
when The Rock first came out with
workout shoes I tried getting them I
tried giving them money
they were legit Have You Ever Seen The
Rocks workout shoes Mark legit you're
the mark
so you he idolizes The Rock I just
figured this out
Brendan idolizes The Rock The Rock is
everything Brendan would look up to yeah
because he said we're the same remember
we're the same me and you he's literally
the meme where it's like that's
literally me yeah he he worships The
Rock but because the rock is doing
something that he isn't like which is
screwing the USC Fighters is what he
thinks anyway right
um
that he's letting him down this is the
eyes of somebody who's been let down
even he was like I was gonna buy the
rock shoes
sold out like this you couldn't get him
I tried get them couldn't get them then
I wanted stocked X hit up my boys at
suplex for like 500 so wait a second
you actually did try to buy the rock
shoes you don't like Under Armor shoes
even though the rock shoes are Under
Armor shoes with a Brahma Bull slapped
on them
because you are that much of a just
consumer huh
you just will consume anything for your
[ __ ] little skill look at the shelves
and all those stupid shows good point
and for the rock with his business come
on bubba you you don't need to reset it
come on Papa
you don't need the money whatever DLC is
paying your business partners to imagine
somebody telling you you don't need the
money hey Brandon you don't need the
money you don't need to do stand up
you're making enough money doing
everything else you don't need the money
you live pretty well compared to me you
don't need the money
for them to wear these shoes you don't
need that money like those are [ __ ]
dope son I would I'm gonna buy those
they're actually looking better aren't
those dope I just don't like that
freaking
um that's his logo he's a bull man I
know I know Rock the bull you know rock
rock your bull
you've never heard of the bull Rocky the
bull
um
I know Rock the bull you know rock the
bowl
is he talking about the rock or is he
talking about Rocky the bull Marciano
well no because it was just Rocky
Marciano
I don't that's what I'm saying though
that's my point though he's mixing up
three different things but he's pulled
here I'll play it again listen watch
this logo he's a bull man I know
Rocky bull Rocky no bra the rocky bull
Rocky Bowl
it didn't make sense yeah trust me
Brendan we know it doesn't make sense no
you're right it didn't make sense and
that's why the rock never got over yeah
no no no you're right that's why they
had to run his ass out and he had to go
to Hollywood because he couldn't cut it
in wrestling some sympathy towards it
now remember the Attitude Era when when
The Rock would come out and cut one of
the greatest promos you'd ever heard in
your life yeah and you'd be like no I
can't connect with this guy because he
has a bull at the same it's not even on
brand
if you could give back to the WWE guys
WWE
I'm sure he would right but that's not
his business but not his business
involved with Doc you're the only part
of this dude you want to be part of this
slave driven business
he really this is I'm telling you this
is Brendan
trying to be little finger yeah and
being like you know I got a lot of
influence in the UFC circles so I bet if
I keep banging this drum I could really
stir some [ __ ] up for old Dana but no
you're not stirring anything up nobody
respects you yeah but instead of
Littlefinger he's little brain exactly
um but he is and he's only doing this
because he's mad at Dana because Dana
said that makes sense too oh well they
both [ __ ] Ronda Rousey allegedly but
um what an unsexy woman yeah
you know damn well you can help these
guys out come on dude I'd I'd be willing
to bet in the next two weeks we get
Fighters are getting compensate for
wearing the rock shoes you know I don't
know a thousand dollars something like
that I would bet my last dollar that
that comes out
I bet Rock wasn't aware of it
probably not he has so much stuff going
on okay
this is such an odd conversation so I
have a feeling that
I guarantee you there's probably the
details of this deal haven't come out
already right but somebody probably
already let it slip to Brendan yeah
they're gonna pay us like a thousand
bucks to to wear the shoes or whatever
and then he's gonna he's probably trying
to make a prediction so he can seem
smart
yeah no I know but nothing will make him
seem smart because when you look at his
face you realize it's a lie he's dumb
[ __ ] stupid idiot